- So, we've known each
other, like a month.
Now we've been on a couple dates.
- Yeah, yup.
- Does sex count as dates?
- I think so, yeah.
That's fair.
- So, like, five or six dates?
(laughing)
(playful music)
I feel like we've done this thing
where we've gotten
drunk and we have, like,
these deep life talks, but then
I don't remember any of them.
- You have to like
retrace the steps again.
- I know you're a D.J.
- Right.
You got that.
- From Boston?
- Yup, nailed it, yeah.
- What do you know about me?
- You are from New Yor--
- Nope.
(laughing)
- Good start.
You live in New York.
- I did live in New York.
- Alright.
- Florida.
- Then you did the BuzzFeed thing.
- That's it?
That's all you know about me?
(laughing)
Uh, what's my favorite food?
Haven't we talked about this a lot?
- Uhhh...
- The point is, we don't
really know each other.
(laughing)
- Yeah, she's right.
- But, we've gone on a few dates.
Seems nice.
You're not a serial
killer that I know of yet.
- Yeah.
- If you find something surprising,
like, I'll probably be surprised, too.
- I'm nervous that I won't be able
to remember why I searched something.
(swishing)
(playful harmonica music)
- Eh, eh, hem.
- Alright.
Red wine and Coke?
- Oh, yeah.
That's my new favorite drink.
- It's great.
- That's the other thing, is we both like
to drink a lot.
- Good play?
- Why are you looking
up prices of Corvettes?
Bowling alley cost.
- So, we were--
- Are you, like, fuckin'
loaded and I don't know it?
(laughing)
Searching Corvettes and bowling alleys?
- I mean, I'm curious about it.
The Cure LA?
(nervous laughing)
- That may or may not be a service
that comes to your house
and gives you an IV drip
for when you're hung over.
- Ohhh.
- Let's talk about that.
- Well, when I hang out with you,
and stay out until fuckin'
three in the morning,
drinking whiskey on a fuckin' work night.
There's a service.
- You gotta love it.
- You just pay a couple
bucks and they come
and they do it in 45 minutes.
Good as new.
- Boom.
A lot of screws here.
For your cabinet, right?
- Mm-hmm, mm-hmm.
You helped me install shelves.
- That's right.
- That was a great move to get laid.
- What is the Coors Light symbol?
(laughing)
Applejack.
- Also great alcohol.
(laughing)
- How to wear a tux.
Do you not know how to wear a tux?
- Well, I wore a tux the
first time in a long time.
I got my own tux, and--
- So do you just put it on?
- Well, yeah.
Maybe there's some other things--
- Or did you need some,
like, confidence tips?
Like, how to wear the shit outta?
- I wanted to know.
When I do things, I do it proper.
I got French cuff shirts.
Never wore those before.
I thought I was supposed
to wear it on the outside,
kinda like a pirate or something,
and then I realized, that's
definitely not what you do.
I just googled pictures of tuxes.
- Goodtimes.co?
It said, good times make you Kelsey?
I love good times?
- Well, I don't know what that is.
- Let's find out.
- Oh, jeez.
- Your shipment is confirmed.
Ohhh.
- What did I order?
- Kelsey's havin' good times.
- Well, I have, like, a
whole drawer of sex toys.
You've seen that, haven't you?
- I haven't.
- Is that a sex shop?
Good Times?
It sounds like it's a sex shop.
- I thought it was the bar.
You wanna know how I know
we're gonna be great together?
How to clean wine glasses properly.
Get you a man who googles that.
- Can't go wrong with that.
Can't go wrong.
You gotta figure it out.
- Did you learn?
How do you do it?
- So, I thought it was just water,
and you actually can use soap too.
- Do you wanna get drinks after this?
- Yeah.
- OK.
- I feel like I could just pull up
my last porn search history,
and that's interesting enough.
- The search is ...
Oh, you just said, "Fucking Hot."
Oh my God.
- That's what I searched for.
(laughing)
- I couldn't think of,
like, a very specific thing,
but I just knew that I
wanted it to be fucking hot.
- That is amazing.
Roll the dice.
- Right.
See if I can jerk off to it.
It's a little game I play.
- I feel like, it wasn't that exciting.
I thought it was going to
be a lot more interesting.
It was kinda pretty tame.
- Nothing I saw made me want to go, like,
ohhh.
- No deal breaker in there?
- I, like, don't want to
hang out with you again.
(romantic string music)
(swishing)
(squeaking hinge)